farmers in southern brazil are feeling
the economic brunt of the war in ukraine
three months after russia's invasion
they're still able to secure fertilizers
for their crops but at very high prices
brazil is the world's largest soy
producer and it's the only international
giant grain producer that is almost
totally dependent on imported
fertilizers 86 of what the country needs
comes from abroad and much of it from
russia and belarus
despite international sanctions against
moscow russian ships are still being
able to dock at brazilian ports
this is not enough for a market as big
as brazil's the war has complicated the
logistics of importing products from
that part of the world generating
insecurity among investors that's why
fertilizer prices have skyrocketed
last year each of these bags with one
ton of fertilizer used to cost six
hundred dollars now farmers are paying
twice as much for the same amount
brazil's president jaibo sonaru visited
moscow shortly before vladimir putin
ordered his troops to invade ukraine
he said latin america's largest economy
would be neutral in the war because
business with russia is fundamental
fertilizers are sacred for us
has the support of brazil's powerful
agricultural lobby even here in
prudentopolis where 75
of the population is of ukrainian
descent and he's running for re-election
in october
what's happening in ukraine is terrible
but brazil has to think about itself it
cannot get involved because 30 percent
of the fertilizers we import come from
russia and belarus
brazil has announced a three-decade plan
to reduce the country's dependence on
imported fertilizers
but experts say it could also take
decades before there are any results
meanwhile farmers in brazil are hoping
for the war to end
monica yanake of al jazeera
prudentopolis brazil